well we all have pasts as we'll find out
today
supposed to us by the careful review of
what Darwin said my passes that I used
to be the struggling professor of
geology and geophysics when I was a
little kid and I grew up and I'm now
emeritus but i also used to be a the
creator of meteorites and Planetary
Science in più I newseum and keith
thompson was my boss i had a every day i
had to go and bow down and say my lord
and then it would allow that but even
farther back something is more
remarkable happen that is i didn't
become a competitor of keith thompson
and biology for a very good reason that
ties in directly with today's speech I
thought for a while at the request of my
mother primarily that I become a medical
missionary so I thinking about taking a
medical course but I of course had to go
through college first and one of the
things that you take when you're in
college if you want to be thinking of
medical school is comparative anatomy
now I went to wheaton college breathing
college produced milligrams it is not a
creationist school it was but it was
tolerated that if you thought
creationism it wasn't wrong and I took
comparative anatomy for a guy who didn't
believe in evolution and as I had SAT
there and dissected my cat and all the
other animals that I did and this guy
would say a common God means a common
creation I said this is nonsense I can't
go through with this and I said I will
abandon biology because the work of the
devil and go into chemistry and that was
what changed my life otherwise that
would have been here competing with
keith thompson for the glories of
biology as he himself is been able to
show to you hey as it is a proficient
member of now keith thompson has done
things to that you may not be aware of
some of them are actually worthy of
talking about and not hidden or subject
to libel and that is a bunch of
fishermen offer an indian ocean quite a
creature that should have died a long
time ago ahead and become extinct was
called coelacanth and the quarters
creature and they brought us it Keith I
guess they figured he'd if anybody would
enjoy eating a QC like an toby keith
thompson instead he did what the
scientists were doing not a good gourmet
he chopped it up and
I didn't understand what is all about
and the world became enriched by the
knowledge of this creature that would
have been smart enough to have died
sometime in the Cretaceous I think but
there any way is not Keith as because of
this has been aware and capable of
understanding all forms of life past and
present and future hopefully future and
as I hope you have a future to be able
to discuss interest and today he's going
to talk about the one guy who tried to
make sense as well of this thing that's
Darwin we heard all about Jefferson last
time today we're going to hear all about
Darwin and Keith can now start talking
if he gets up here in time
Oh Carl thank you I had I forgotten how
much I missed the morning bowing and
scraping became a real habit I was going
to say those were the days but they
don't want to do that it's a long time
ago since I was on the faculty here at
Yale and it's so nice to see many of my
friends from those days here I really
like to thank the Terry committee for
inviting me to give this series of
lectures which as I said on Tuesday is
really an awesome responsibility I would
like to mention lauralee field who from
the office of the university secretary
who has looked after Lyndon myself with
a care and a grace that we are
absolutely not a used to but want to be
so we'll try and keep that up and i also
want to mention jean thompson black
executive editor at the yale university
press i have to mention a cushy yet it's
my books and if I if I get on the wrong
side of Jean I'm in serious trouble so
excuse me in my last lecture I said what
I wanted to do at least in the first two
lectures will look at this whole
question of the relationship between
science and religion and this so-called
conflict between the two from a
different point of view from most people
because this seems to me as i said the
there is the great dramatic image of
galileo and the tribunal but the much
more interesting thing or at least as
interesting thing to me is Galileo for
the first time realizing there was
something dramatically important that he
needed to investigate that was going to
turn his whole life upside down and not
necessarily for the better when Thomas
Jefferson looked at geology which he
loved
and how it fitted with his view of
religion and particularly with creation
he found that they didn't meet at all
and as I showed he gave up geology he
just closed his mind to the whole
subject and stayed with his religious
views what I want to do today is talk
about Charles Darwin who very similarly
came against this conflict between his
scientific views and his religious views
scientific views that he'd actually
created for himself brand new science or
of natural selection and how he dealt
with the problem and he was very
different from Thomas Jefferson because
he was a quintessential warrior who
would never let anything drop in the way
that Jefferson managed to do one of the
things that I mentioned in my last
lecture was that it's hard to find
things that are really new in this
subject things seem to be repeated over
and over the natural theology at paley
in 1801 was just an echo of John Ray's
the wisdom of God manifest in the works
of his creation published in eighteen I
mean 1670 odd and then also was
completely there in cicero's de natura
de orem on the nature of the gods to the
first century BC or similarly evolution
as what we call evolution which was
previously called development theory or
transmutation theory was around well
before Charles Darwin was born his
grandfather Erasmus Darwin popularized
the subject and his ideas were taken up
by jean-baptiste Lamarck everybody knows
about Lamarckian evolution and in 1844
the subject was made immensely popular
by the work of a man it was anonymous at
first but it turned out to be Robert
Chambers in Scotland who wrote a book
called vestiges of the natural
tree of creation it was immensely
popular because the 1840s were a time of
great social oppressed and even
revolution in particularly across the
channel in Europe and it was a message
of change that people weren't stuck in
their natural little slot to which God
had assigned them our society to sign
them but there was room for if you like
the cat to look at the king and of
course the scientists absolutely hated
it largely because a lot of what he
wrote of his geological science was
actually as it turned out to be even
then wrong but didn't matter because it
was immensely popular and that counts so
it was probably chambers that Tennyson
was thinking about in in memoriam which
as you know was written in 1849 when he
wrote about nature red in tooth and claw
and even more pertinently our God and
nature then at strife that nature lends
such evil dreams so careful of the type
she seems so scarce careless of the
single life there is Darwinian natural
selection in a nutshell the individuals
are sacrificed in order that the type is
preserved and he was only capturing
again the ideas of Thomas Malthus on
population and indeed the French
botanist de candolle who had written all
nature is at war with itself so these
sorts of ideas were very much in the air
when Charles Darwin was a young man and
particularly when he came back from the
Beagle one of my favorite references to
development theory from before Darwin is
the following from a novel of 1847 you
know all is development the principle is
perpetually going on first there was
nothing then there was something then I
forget the next I think there were
shells then fishes then we came let's
see did we come next nevermind we came
at last and the next change there will
be something very superior to
something with wings that's it we were
fishes and I believe we shall be close
that was Benjamin Disraeli in his novel
tankard now Disraeli was a pretty good
writer actually but Jefferson and Darwin
were remarkable writers they both wrote
so simply and with such clarity we only
have to think of the Declaration of
Independence and Darwin's Origin of
Species can easily be given to writing
composition classes today 150 years
after its publication most of what he
wrote was quite expository but a few
passages are quite lyrical and
everybody's favorite choice obviously
but I'm going to rehearse it for you
anyway though you could probably recite
it along with me it's the last paragraph
of the Origin of Species it is
interesting to complement contemplate an
entangled Bank clothed with many plants
of many kinds with birds singing in the
bushes with various insects flitting
about and with worms crawling through
the damp earth and to reflect that these
elaborately constructed forms so
different from each other and dependent
on each other and so complex a manner
have all been produced by laws acting
around us and then skipping forwards
thus from the war of nature from famine
and death the most exalted object we are
capable of conceiving namely the
production of higher animals directly
follows there is grandeur in this view
of life with itself for all powers
having been originally breathed into a
few forms or into one and that whilst
the planet has gone cycling on according
to the ficks law of gravity from so
simple a beginning endless forms most
beautiful and most wonderful have been
and are being evolved it's a lovely
passage and that interesting thing about
it is this phrase
this view of life having been breathed
into a few forms or one what did he mean
by breathed by now he very carefully
left it it could be sort of literal it
could be figurative it could be a
wonderful metaphor he just left it there
and I suppose nobody paid very much
attention to it anyway one obvious
rhetorical purpose of this glorious
paragraph is to end the book on a very
silly racal and upbeat note because so
much of it involved what Tennyson had
referred to V the nature red in tooth
and claw favorite survival of favorite
races meant the not survival of a great
deal of others direct and indirect
struggle competition disease want all
those things drive natural selection so
that nature's full of ugliness as well
as beauty so what darwin is doing here
in this grandeur of this view of life
when it all depends on such competition
and nastiness is he's setting a direct
antithesis to the natural theology of
the Paley and andray and in an early
version which he wrote out in ninth 1844
and didn't publish that was the year
that chambers did publish and I'm sure
there's a connection with the delay he
said it accords with what we know of the
laws impressed by the creator or matter
that the production and extinctions of
forms should like the birth and death of
individuals be the result of secondary
means it is derogatory that the creator
of countless universes should have made
by individual acts of his will the
myriads of creeping parasites and worms
which since the earliest days of life
have swarmed over the land and in the
depths of the Seas we cease to be
astonished that a group of animals
should have been formed to lay their
eggs in the bowels and flesh of other
sensitive beings that some animals
should live by and
delighting cruelty that animal should be
led away by false instincts and that
annually they should be an incalculable
waste of pollen eggs and immature beings
for and all this we see the inevitable
consequences have one great law and then
he wrote there is a symbol grandeur in
this view of life and that was the early
draft of 1844 he's actually setting up
an argument against two ideas that were
incredibly important and universal at
the time one was natural theology that
God had made everything the way it is
and it was all beautiful and the other
one was that described how we had so
much diversity on the face of the earth
as people explored across the globe
through the seventeenth and eighteenth
and early nineteenth century it became
almost imponderable why there was so
many different kinds of animals and
plants when in theory just one or two
where it would have been would it be
fine why were tho kangaroos and
wallabies in Australia but not in Africa
why they were polar bears in the north
and penguins in the south but not vice
versa how did this extraordinary
strangeness of diversity come apart
about and the prevailing theory was that
God had created it that way and what he
had done was created life at at least 50
different centres of creation and so
each centre was different the australian
centre was different from the south
american center the north american from
the european and so on this is sort of
what i referred to earlier as being
saving the phenomenon if you think about
it noah's ark could not have cooked with
the problem of why there were Wallabies
and kangaroos in australia if after the
flood everything had been restored to
wear to the middle east
so this theory was called the theory of
special creation and it was an important
theory at the time that diamond was
writing and clearly he was recruiting
against it and excuse me I view all
beings not a special creations but it's
the lineal descendants of some few
beings which live long ago before the
first bed of the Silurian system was
deposited they if I do that then they
seemed to me to be ennobled which is
kind of an interesting word so he was
proposing a new kind of secular grace in
no bling that did not deny the existence
for creator it just assigned to the
Creator only the job of setting things
going in the first place and after that
everything went by secondary laws and if
you think about that that works out
quite well because community gets the
credit for all the good things and all
this mayhem and whatnot by which
evolution actually a natural selection
actually happens is just the result of
the secondary laws that happen Willy
nearly once you've set things going so
downwards writing about this in first
end started writing lines in 1838 just
two years after he came back from the
Beagle voyage and he didn't publish the
origin until 1859 during that time his
religious views changed immensely and I
want to talk a little about that now
Darwin was brought up as a in a curious
but not on common combination of
unitarianism and the Church of England
unitarianism was very popular in the
Midlands part of England the new
industrial heartland of England less so
in the capital and not so much at all in
Scotland but it was there when men
tended to be self-made and both men and
women were really encouraged to think
for themselves and this was the
religious preference of the wedge woods
his cousin's he married a wedgwood his
father married a wedgwood and also his
days grandfather Erasmus Darwin Robert
Darwin Charles Darwin's father was
brought up as a Unitarian and then moved
over to the Church of England because
that was the very fashionable logical
thing to do and in fact despite both of
those connections he was a non-believer
Darwin was christened at Shrewsbury
parish church but never confirmed his
wife-to-be emma wedgwood was also an
ardent Unitarian but she was confirmed
in the Church of England at the age of
18 a dominant feature of Unitarians
obviously was their insistence that the
discovery of truth about God and Jesus
could come through only through personal
study and reflection rather than dogma
this was the approach that Jefferson
also followed and as for Jefferson
intelligent reflection was something
that Charles Darwin and Emma were
particularly good at as a young boy of
16 when he went to Edinburgh to medical
school he was probably as a religious as
any sixteen-year-old boy might be
expected to be he and his older brother
Rasmus spent the first semester going
round from church to church hoping to
find a really good fire and brimstone
preaching and there were largely
disappointed and they wrote a very sad
little letter to his sister Caroline
from Edinburgh asking for advice what
part of the Bible do you like best I
like the Gospels do you know which one
of them is reckoned to be the best well
as you know medicine and Charles Darwin
didn't fit together but it is a surprise
still that his father then sent him to
Cambridge to learn to be a Church of
England priest I see wrote in his in his
autobiography I do not think the
religious sentiment was ever strongly
developed in me but he had to have a
career of some sort so he mugged up his
Greek and Latin
made sure that he could swear to the
thirty-nine articles of the Church of
England and went to Cambridge and was a
quick study when he was on the Beagle
immediately after Cambridge he wrote i
was quite Orthodox and I remember being
heartily laughter by several of the
officers for quoting the Bible as a non
unanswerable authority on some point and
morality I suppose it was the novelty of
the argument that amuse them but I
gradually came to see that the Old
Testament from its manifestly false
history of the world with the Tower of
Babel that rainbow is a sign etc etc and
from its attributing to God the feelings
of a vengeful tyrant was no more to be
trusted than the sacred books of the
Hindus or the beliefs of any barbarian
so he had changed now when he was on the
Beagle voyage he realized he would never
have to be a person because he would
have his mother's fortune when he was 25
and his father's fortune when the old
man died and that was several millions
of pounds so he was never going to have
to have a job and of course as you know
he never did have a paid job what he
seems to be in hoping for that he could
become like his teacher the Reverend
John Stevens henslowe at Cambridge
adorned at Cambridge perhaps with a
little secure living in a church
somewhere with accurate to take care of
it for him I don't know how many of you
have taken the train from London to
Oxford but as you do just before you get
to Oxford on the right hand side of the
train there's lovely fields that in the
distance there there's this beautiful
little church 12th century squat little
church it doesn't have a steeple or
anything and it's Chelsea church and
Stephens Henslow's that was his church
that he relied upon for an income it's
also strangely enough the place where I
get the Christie is buried anyway so it
was on the Beagle voice that he started
to have really serious doubts about
creation and from the point of view of
geology there was one thing to read in
boo
how broken up the earth was as I was
talking about in the last lecture but it
was quite a different thing to go out to
South America and see it all for
yourself and not only to see how it
seemed to be broken up and to have read
about the great earthquake of Lisbon at
1755 but when they were concepcion chile
there was a massive earthquake right
under their feet and the big officers
were surveyors and they worked it out
before and afterwards that the land in
places have been raised eight or ten
feet in one afternoon which led some
credence to the view that maybe remember
the question of where the mountains come
from is it being driven up by
earthquakes and volcanoes gave some
credence to that view and it was a
geologist as he came back from the
Beagle voyage he set out to be a
geologist he was setting out to write a
book on coral reefs and to write the
geology of South America in fact which
he did in two volumes and one of the
first things he did was to take an
unpaid position as secretary of the
geological society of london he was
clearly on this trajectory to be a
geologist but he also had a completely
opposite secret life which started to
eat away at him because it was only six
months after he came back from the
Beagle voyage that he realized this
species must transmute or developed
species must change and that he thought
he could find a way a mechanism for that
to happen which no one else had ever
done not a modest ambition for a young
26 year old he finished the outline of
his theory in 1838 and almost exactly
the same time married emma wedgwood Emma
who was possibly one of the most devout
Christian believers in all of England
and you can only guess at the conflicts
that arose between the two they
continued to check attend church
together and on the moat for the moment
all was calm on the surface but he later
confided to a friend
and in a phrase that it's very familiar
to you it's like confessing to a murder
he was working secretly publicly
straightforward acceptable geologists he
was working on a theory that would
subvert as his wife's religion if there
was a if there was ever a case where
there is a tax on new knowledge in the
phrase that J a Thompson used in the
very first of these Terry lectures in
1925 this must be the case because the
tax the price that Darwin paid for
working on this theory which he knew
would not be very acceptable really
almost did cost him his life for the
rest of his life for instance in his
study there was always a curtain alcove
where he could retire during the day as
the pressure got too much turned to
throw up your pardon the expression now
on the advice of his father he actually
opened his heart to amer about his
doubts very dangerous thing to do my
father advised me to carefully conceal
my doubts or he said that he had known
extreme misery thus caused by married
persons things went pretty well until
the wife or husband became out of health
and then some women suffered miserably
by doubting about salvation of their
husbands thus making them to suffer
likewise my father added that he had
known only is it he had known during his
whole long life only three women who
were skeptics it's interesting medallion
couldn't keep any secret from Emma and
so he told her about his doubts and even
before they were married it was a
tremendous tremendous problem as she
wrote to him when I am with you i think
all Melek only thoughts about keep out
of my head but since you are gone some
sad ones have forced themselves in a
fear that our opinions on the most
important subject would differ widely my
reason tells me that honest and
conscientious doubts cannot be
a sin but I feel it would be a painful
void between us I thank you from my
heart for your openness with me and I
should read the feeling that you were
concealing your opinions from fear of
giving me pain sometime between his
marrying Emma in 1838 and the death of
his father in 18-49 he gave up all
belief in conventional Christianity and
the DD wrote in his autobiography
afterwards though I guess all altar bar
is a little suspect there's a lot of
déjà our view there but I can hardly see
how anyone ought to which Christianity
be to be true for for if so the plain
language of the text seems to show that
men who do not believe and this would
include my father brother and almost all
my best friends will be everlastingly
punished and this is a damnable doctrine
now if you think about it was he making
a pun their everlasting Pope punishment
damnable document who knows anyway
Darwin died that Robert Darwin died in
in 1848 and then in 1851 his little
daughter Annie died the subject of a
brilliant book by Darwin's
great-grandson Randall Keynes called in
this country anyway in England is called
a nice box it has if they're different
title here but it's if you want to eat
anything about the Darwin family read
Randall Keynes's book so thus a
disbelief crept over me at a very slow
rate but it was at last complete the
rate was so slow that i felt no distress
movement never since doubted for a
single second that my conclusion was
correct but he still believed in the
existence of God and he still basically
agreed with the natural theology
argument that it was impossible that man
that this wonderful universe including
man with his capacity for looking far
backwards of far into Futurity was the
result of blind child
or necessity thus reflecting I feel the
Sri Fleck ting I feel compelled to look
to a first cause having an intelligent
mind in some degree analogous to that of
a man and I deserve to be called a
theist and then of course this being
Darwin and immediately starts to take it
back now hope you don't mind my reading
it another passage here but then arises
the doubt and the doubt is whether the
human mind can actually be trusted on
this subject may not always be the
result of a connection between cause and
effect but problem which probably
depends on inherited experience the
probability that the constant ill
kincaid inculcation of a belief in god
of the minds of children producing so
strong and perhaps an inherited effect
on their brains not yet fully developed
that they would that it would be as
difficult for them to throw off their
belief with God as for a monkey to throw
of its instinctive fear and hatred of a
snake now in his 1871 the descent of man
he goes into great deal detail into
subjects that are still very important
today which is whether a sense of
religion is something that has a natural
selective adaptive value that could
actually be selected for in natural
selection so as he traveled around the
world he realized that this theory of
special creation wouldn't work and when
he came back and set off to study
natural selection and evolution as I
said before it was a very immodest goal
he said to himself he wrote down in his
notebook what he was going to create was
not just a mechanism for evolution it
would be a new system of natural history
with capital letters and psychology will
be based on a new foundation
white will be thrown on the origin of
man and history it was going to be a
complete new world view now when the
book came out it had a very mixed
reception I want to read to you one
because I really like this one this was
from his old teacher Adam Sedgwick the
geologist at Cambridge if I did not
think you were good tempered and
truthful loving man I should not tell
you that in spite of the great knowledge
store of fact capital views of
correlations of the various parts of
organic nature admirable hints about the
diffusion through wide regions and
nearly related organic beings etc etc
etc I have read your book with more pain
than pleasure parts of it I greatly
admired parts i laughed until my sides
were almost saw others parts I've read
with absolute sorrow because I think
then utterly false and grievously
mischievious now in 1878 the Reverend EB
pusey at Oxford gave a sermon at some
Mary's Church the the university church
it's a famous sermon called science and
not science and it's remarkable because
in this sermon science having advanced
immensely in the period in the 19th
century pewsey was willing to grant
science almost all of its discoveries it
didn't care whether the earth was
millions and millions of years old that
was very radical for a cleric Church of
England cleric at the time he insisted
only two points that the initial
creation of life was divine and
miraculous and the exceptionalism of
human origins other species might evolve
he would grant that but human evolution
origin required divine intervention and
he made a stranger accusation against
Darwin
it was then so far with a quasi
theological not a scientific object that
he wrote his book what did he mean by
that Darwin wishes to overthrow the
theory of knack of special creations so
this is a very interesting subject that
people have discussed a great deal was
special creations of theological theory
or a scientific theory and if Darwin is
arguing against it is he writing a quasi
theological book or a totally scientific
book of course this made Darwin
absolutely furious furious he said he
there's nothing was further from my mind
than to write what pewsey has written
about me which of course was completely
false that's exactly what he did from
beginning to end Darwin's book is a
demolition of the theory of special
creations and if that isn't bad enough
when he wrote the introduction to the
1878 e71 descent of man he said oops
have I lost it I had two objects in view
if I've heard in giving natural
selection great power blah blah blah I
have at least I hope done good service
and aiding to overthrow the dogma of
special creation this is an
extraordinary thing he's writing letters
to all those friends complaining about
pewsey talking about them accuse him in
not believing in God which which he
clearly did in some way mother but how
could he have claimed that he wasn't
destroying the theory of special
creations when that's exactly what he
set out to do so if that's puzzling the
next thing is even more puzzling
confronted with as he was with this
tremendous tension between his
scientific view and conventional
religious views
what did he do in a word he blinked now
he'd known all along that this would be
very unpopular this theory of his but no
sooner the origin had come out which I
think was either October or November of
1859 he worked on a second edition which
came out in January of eighteen sixty so
just a few months and then he yielded to
temptation as i said the devil whispered
into his ear with just a few judicious
additions you could appeal to at least
or at least appease your religious
argument audience the acceptance of your
ideas would be far greater if you added
a phrase or two emphasizing a role for
the might Almighty now who the devil is
who spoke to dr. Darwin that we don't
know but it's a very good chance it was
a man called the Reverend Charles
Kingsley I don't know if Charles
Kingsley is familiar to you he is he's
famous for having written at one of the
most ghastly Victorian children's books
of all time called the water babies
water babies are very useful in my
career because when I was giving it to
read at about the age of 80 showed me
that teachers and parents could actually
be extremely stupid this was the worst
mayor most meretricious sentimental
ghastly book I ever read and you know
what Here I am I still can't get it out
of my system anyway so what did I when
do well he added a little epigraph at
the beginning from a book by samuel
butler in which he which samuel butler
tries to define what is natural and what
is natural is if i may find the place oh
I'm sorry here we go what is natural as
much requires and presupposes an
intelligent agent to render it that is
affected continually or at stated times
as what is supernatural or miraculous
does to affect it for
once he's saying that it's an edging
backwards 22 natural theology again now
he does also say I don't see any good
reason why the views given this volume
she's shocked through religious feelings
of anyone a celebrated author and divine
has written to me that he has gradually
learned that it's just as noble a
conception of the deity to believe that
he created a few original forms capable
of self development into other and
needful forms as to believe that he
required a fresh act of creation to
supply the voids caused by the actions
of his laws that probably was Charles
Kingsley and up to on his site it has to
be said that he was one of the first
church of england clerics to accept the
idea of Darwinian evolution the other
one being the Reverend baden-powell the
professor of geometry at Oxford who was
the father of Baden Powell the founder
of scouting but then he made another
edition and this is what is really
upsetting you remember this phrase there
is grandeur in this look view of life
with its several powers having
originally been having having been
originally breathed into a few forms or
into one now it read in the second
edition there is grandeur in this view
of life having been originally breathed
by the Creator into a few forms or one
what in the first edition he had left as
open to interpretation was it literal or
figurative had now been answered it was
literally breathed by the Creator a big
difference or a small difference he was
mortified by this he never got over the
fact that he had succumbed to this
pressure and had had catered to
convention he wrote to his friend hooker
I have long regretted that I truck'll to
public opinion and used the Pentateuch
whole term of Croatia creation by which
I really meant at
here by some wholly unknown process it's
me rubbish thinking a present of origin
of life one might as well think of the
origin of matter and there are lots of
other letters like this it's it's sort
of interesting to wonder why it must
have been something to do with Emma that
persuaded him to add that but he always
realized that he'd dug himself into a
hole that he couldn't get out of and for
the rest of his life he was completely
ambivalent on the question of religion
my theology is a simple model I cannot
look at the universe as a result of
blind chance and yet I can see no
evidence of beneficence design or indeed
of design of any kind in the details
other letters he had talked happily
about design and finally he said I can
hardly see how religion and science can
be septus kept as distinct as the
Reverend pewsey desires but I must
wholly agree that there was no reason
why the disciples of either school
should attack each other with bitterness
and this was the big problem once he had
published the origin people took up
cudgels on both sides and the debate
became extremely vituperative and very
unpleasant and of course everybody
constantly tried to enlist him on their
side and so for the rest of his life
which was 30 years he was constantly
dodging from one foot to the other
trying to avoid being sucked in by some
clever ploy into endorsing some
particular view or other and he never
did he stayed completely neutral in the
great debates that arose after but the
personal cost the tax that was paid in
having come to this question of how he
would resolve the issue of science and
religion and as I said blinking rather
than sticking to
his original guns or indeed coming out
wholeheartedly for a religious point of
view continue to eat at him and as you
know he was one of the most unwell
physically people of the 19th century so
both Jefferson and Darwin were very
private people and that's part of the
issue to both were damned if they did
and damned if they didn't not religious
enough for some people to religious for
others Jefferson backed away from
science by giving up geology and Darwin
compromised ever so slightly now this
isn't the conflict between science and
religion that's often presented which is
the contest between two great
authorities gutting head-to-head this is
the process of testing new knowledge
against old which happens in every field
not just science and religion and it
happens every day and it happens all of
us some people can close their minds and
some people which I suspect is the
majority of us continue to worry now in
my next lecture I'm going to see how a
80 after eighteen sixty we move from the
individuals that we've been talking
about to how authority came to join the
debate and literally the debates because
I'm going to talk about the will repose
Huxley Oxford debate of eighteen sixty
and also the much less well-known
debates in Massachusetts which actually
preceded the Wilberforce debates and
along the way I will try to discover for
you whether thomas henry huxley actually
had an ape or a grandmother thank
Oh double-barreled question that's a
real bear trap second part has science
shown that there is no need for the
hypothesis of a selective value for a
religious belief I'm not sure that you
can say that I think you could well
argue that there's a very strong
selective advantage societal advantage
in a religious belief for a lot of
people and for society for societies you
could also I give that it's not
necessary that everything have been said
by Aristotle anyway on the subject of
morals and ethics and whatnot but on the
other hand as i said in my first lecture
in a way it doesn't matter if enough
people believe in God then it's
something that you have to take it take
into comas that's every time you you
open your big fat mouth which is what
I've been doing today but there is a
considerable and active and still very
contentious but a group of people trying
to show that moral behavior and
including a belief in a higher power is
something that can be actively selective
for as a result of sort of put it
crudely the enlightened self-interest of
small related groups of people that in
that that that's that selective regime
there is that it's perfectly possible
something like that could could arise
and be maintained because there is there
is an advantage so this is one of the
places where science is if you like
running up against religion
again again by trying to explain in
purely material terms something that it
seems more in the rep that used to be
more in the realm of morals and ethics
rather than atoms and chance so so I
think the answer is well there are a lot
of people working at this and so I don't
be fun to be flippant but there is the
joke about the Southern Baptist preacher
who was asked if he believed in him from
baptism and he thought for a moment he
said I've seen it done so with this case
it's perfectly possible yes but very
difficult because the scientists have
not yet if they ever going to nail it
down they certainly haven't nailed it
down now other questions lately I do
read a great deal about this this issue
that you mentioned and what lately I've
been thinking a lot of it about how
belief as distinct from faith is
sometimes disclosed as a to me as as
where the accent is on the commitment
rather than it being an epistemic
statement I mean a statement belief of
belief often says I don't have enough
evidence to convince you of this and so
I'm going to use the word I believe or
it may mean I question the whole yep is
no logical structure of this discipline
that I'm talking about and therefore I'm
going to just say I believe it is sort
of there's some sense of commitment and
I've as a very you know liberal religion
as I I still sometimes admire
fundamentalists whom I would disagree
with often because there seems to be the
sense of commitment and fidelity and I'm
going to stand by God no matter what
anyone says and I wonder with Darwin
whether there is some kind of struggle
like
we're from a from a pis'mo logical point
of view he's saying I can't add this up
but he still has some sense of
commitment I think that's right yes and
I think I would agree with you also
about sort of em being Lee those who are
absolutely certain and he but he I think
just the fact that he he had the sort of
mind that constantly probed into every
direction he couldn't find a certainty
that he could hold on to that's the best
way I can put it but but the word
believe is actually it's actually
fascinating to me because people will
say I believe in evolution and I've
never know people who are accused of
believing in evolution and it's again
what we know is a mixture of what we
actually know from personal experience
and what we have from others and so when
we say we believe in evolution at least
the layman probably means I except
possibly for the time being I accept the
theory of evolution but I think when
people anywhere in a scientific subjects
say I believe this particular piece of
science I think it does the whole system
a terrible this surface so I worry with
you about this this difference because
it does seem to see that okay well maybe
it's just an item of faith with these
people they they don't actually know
anything they just believe in evolution
because it's fashionable or something
yes
I didn't Darwin who eventually attached
some credence to Wallace's argument that
natural selection couldn't account for
the evolution of brains that could do
trigonometry that is savages didn't need
this and and therefore there was no
evolutionary pressure to have it an
argument we would now consider racist
but was widely believed in the 19th
century and didn't Darwin eventually
come to test him cringe tonight Vincent
didn't Darwin what didn't he eventually
attach some credence to this argument
didn't he accept it to some degree um
not by the time he came to write the
descent of man no he was no definitely
not i I'm not in my reading anyway I
believe he he he was perfectly because
the whole thing was gradation for him so
you didn't just start with trigonometry
you started with something much simpler
and simpler you built and you built in
your bills so I wasn't a problem for him
I believe certainly that's not what he
writes in the in the in the descent of
man
hi um so you mentioned that Darwin was
writing a quazy theological rather than
a scientific with it Kwazii theological
angle or at least that's what Reverend
Pusey said I was wondering what are the
implications of that like accusation and
or what was over Reverend Posey's
implications I think it was it was I
think it was the in a way it was the
ultimate put-down here was this great
preacher dismissing Darwin's great
science as quasi theology amateur style
of quasi theology sort of amateur
theology but also with straight forward
that he was committed to this theory of
special creation and Darwin and so were
the vast majority of the population of
Britain and indeed I'll show in the
United States at that time so it was it
was a serious affront to his whole
philosophical viewpoint that Darwin
should have attacked this and because it
was a quasi-religious theory the theory
of special creation then it was you sort
of finish up a confusing Darwin of
having him written the quasi theological
book and so he was furious because it
wasn't intended as a theological book
although it was intended as a foot down
over quite a theological theory so it's
it's the problem but i think it was
partly a put-down a boozy need to lead
it to use every every stratagem to
discredit darwin and interesting enough
it didn't appear in the sermon itself he
wrote it in a footnote to the published
version of the sermon that appeared two
days late early in the Guardian
newspaper sorry can you just ask part do
you think the Darwin could have ridden
in in a purely scientific angle that
didn't
how many was ideological wait Tony say
say it again I'm sorry do you think that
Darwin could have written origin of
species or any of his other works from a
purely scientific angle rather than a
theological I think he thought that's
what he did he scientifically destroyed
a theological or quasi theological
theory but he saw himself as writing
purely as a scientist that's that's the
robe do do you think Darwin had a
conceptualization of the huge impact of
evolutionary theory on biology to where
perhaps these compromises he may have
done with regard to inserting creator
into the discussion would essentially be
forgiven by history and what sense have
no impact on evolution being accepted by
Allah by biologists globally near
immediately as it was well let's put it
this way the scientific content of his
writings is both the the origin and that
particularly the Descent of Man which
was very revolutionary book was so
strong that you could read all of that
and never and just not notice that he
ever used the word creator or even that
he bothered very much was a theory of
special creations if you read it from a
particular viewpoint you just just read
it straight through he certainly was a
hope that the theory of natural
selection would spread out and explain
as i said this great system of nature
that it would explain everything and by
the time he died it really had gone a
long way to doing that people have
picked it up in every possible respect
so by a sort of 1860 there was already a
social Darwinism applied to the history
of a european country
for instance it really did take a take
off very fast and I think it's only in
retrospect that it's interesting to
reconstruct Darwin's life and see how
what he seemed to be doing so
effortlessly in so many accounts of
Darwin what seemed to be so effortlessly
was actually achieved at this enormous
personal cost of torment and conflict
and then I like to turn that round and
say well that's not so very different
from what we do on a much more minor
scale that we have to do all the time
our selves whenever we come across with
something that doesn't quite fit with
what we've been told but the I think
there was this view that it was all so
effortless and now the view of Darwin is
that he this was a man who was
absolutely tortured and pretty much from
the moment in 1838 when he realized he
had the idea and married Emma
did Darwin know much about what was
going on in biblical scholarship in
Germany in the 19th century where there
were people who are making distinctions
about sources and treating the biblical
text quite differently than what he had
learned in England well that's
fascinating because I talked about this
a little bit with respect to whether
Jefferson did in and it was clear that
he did because he wrote to Adams saying
he pretty much exactly that he is
there's nothing in his writing that
suggests it very much does the does the
odd thing that appears in the
autobiography about the the Bible being
you know in the rainbow sign or being
nonsense like the books of the Hindus
one arm to be offensive nowadays but he
has to have noticed because as I'm sure
you were leading up to saying in
eighteen sixty they book essays and
reviews was published in which the
German scholarship a particular
Christian bunsen was just thrust into
the middle of this huge argument within
the church of england and how could he
not have noticed this i mean when it
finishes up with ecclesiastical trials
for heresy and whatnot I mean this is a
huge deal and his teachers at Cambridge
certainly were well aware of this
because in Buckley so this is a bit
technical I'm sorry but in Buckland's
Bridgewater Bridgewater treatise volume
the same Reverend EB pusey as a young
man tells Buckland that it's okay
because the word made doesn't mean
created out of nothing the Germans have
told us that it's all something
different so he has to enough I think
it's simply a subject that he didn't
care to engage and he didn't need to to
produce it as evidence for his point of
view
so he surely knew about it but he didn't
he didn't bother to drag it up but
funnily enough i'm going to talk a bit
about that in my next next lecture